- [Voiceover] We're told that F of seven
is equal to 40 plus five,
E to the seventh power,
and F prime of X is equal to five,
E to the X.
What is F of zero?
So to evaluate F of zero,
let's take the anti-derivative
of F prime of X,
and then we're going to have a constant
of integration there,
so we can use the information
that they gave us up here
that F of seven is equal to this.
This might look like an expression.
Well, it is an expression,
but it's really just a number.
There's no variables in this,
and so we can use that to solve
for our constant of integration,
and then we will have fully known
what F of X is,
and we can use that to evaluate F of zero,
so let's just do it.
So if F prime of X is
equal to five, E to the X,
then F of X is going to be equal
to the anti-derivative of F prime of X,
or the anti-derivative
of five, E to the X, DX,
and this is the thing
that I always find amazing
about exponentials,
and actually, let me just take a step.
I'll take that five out of the integral
so it becomes a little bit more obvious.
And so the anti-derivative of E to the X,
well, that's just E to the X
because the derivative of E to the X
is E to the X,
which I find amazing every time
I have to manipulate
or take the derivative
or anti-derivative of E to the X.
So this is gonna be
five, E to the X, plus C,
and you can verify.
Take the derivative of
five, E to the X, plus C.
The derivative of five, E to the X,
well, that's five, E to the X,
so that works out.
Well, and the derivative of C is zero,
so you wouldn't see it over here.
So now, let's use this information
to figure out what C is
so that we know exactly what F of X is,
and then we can evaluate F of zero.
So we know that F of seven,
so when X is equal to seven,
this expression is going
to evaluate to this thing,
40 plus five, E to the seven.
So, five times E to the seventh power
plus C is equal to 40, plus five,
E to the seventh power.
And notice, all I did is say, okay,
F of seven.
Well, if this is F of X--
Let me write this down.
So, if this is F of seven,
if this is F of X,
I just replaced the X with a seven
to find F of seven,
and we know that F of seven is also going
to be equal to that.
They gave us that information,
but when you just look at this,
it's pretty easy to figure
out what C is going to be.
You can subtract five, E to the seven
from both sides,
and you see that C is equal to 40.
And so we can rewrite F of X.
We can say that F of X is equal
to five, E to the X,
plus C, which is 40.
And so now, from that,
we can evaluate F of zero.
F of zero is going to be five times
E to the zero power, plus 40.
E to the zero is one,
so it's gonna be five times one,
which is just five, plus 40,
which is equal to 45,
and we're done.